hello freak [ __ ] when did the start
when did the trigger warnings when to
the safe spaces when did all this emerge
well it has its roots in the student
radicalism of the 1960's especially the
far-left radicalism it really popped up
in the 1990s in the early 90s when I was
teaching in the US at that point and
which universe I taught at Harvard from
93 to 98 and there was a fair push for
political correctness especially in the
early part of the 90s but but it got
pushed back down and disappeared and
went underground it went on the ground
is more accurate and then it's just come
back with a vengeance in the last five
years and I think it's partly because we
have all these radical left political
activist departments at the universities
women's studies being at the top of the
of the list that have done nothing for
the last 30 years to even longer than
that now it's almost 40 years 30 years
let's say have done nothing but produce
a never-ending stream of ideological he
minded counter civilization political
activists and that's all subsidized by
by tuition and by the public purse and
that's another thing we really got to
ask ourselves is why the hell are we
subsidizing revolution why are we doing
that it's crazy and it's dangerous it's
dangerous what so what exactly is going
on with women's studies that you believe
is fostering revolution well you go on
their websites and read read what they
say I mean first of all for the for the
women's studies types and this is a what
would you call it false
anthropology there's this idea that way
back when there was a feminist paradise
and that would be like noble savage mode
of living where everything was
egalitarian and and women dominated it
was a matriarchal culture that was put
forward by a UCLA anthropologist named
Gambia Tess I can never pronounce her
name property but I think I got it and
then that was overthrown by patriarchal
institutions start essentially starting
at about the time say of the of Judaism
and that was all overthrown and ever
since then we've lived in an oppressive
patriarchy and now that's what our
culture is it's an oppressive patriarchy
so they're pointing to one unsuccessful
society that they believed existed or
did not exist no it didn't exist there's
no evidence for whatsoever it's it's
it's complicated but it's the it's the
telling of a kind of psychological myth
as if it was history whoa and and and
anyway so so the basic claim is that
Western civilization is a brutish
patriarchy and that whatever positive
things it might have managed to
accomplish were all accomplished as a
consequence of oppression and and and
theft and that the appropriate thing to
do is to restructure it from the bottom
up and they mean that they mean that
they mean every single bloody concept
and you can marry that with modern
post-modernism and throw in a nice dash
of Marxism and you have the the
ideological and motivated grounds for
social revolution and just go online and
look at a dozen Women's Studies websites
just read them you can see what they say
they produce political activists and
their goal is to restructure the
patriarchy well what's the patriarchy
well the patriarchy is Western
civilization and what is restructure
mean that's easy
it means tear it down and destroy it why
because it's a brutish system that's
predicated on nothing but oppression
it's nothing but a tyranny and in the
eyes of the of the radical women studies
types heterosexuality
that's a tyranny capitalism that's a
tyranny democracy well that doesn't even
exist and even if it did it would be a
tyranny everything's a tyranny and so
you can ask these and and what would
they replace it with they replace it
with their own ideological utopia well
we've already had a hundred years of
that we saw what happened oh well that
doesn't matter that wasn't real Marxism
that's what the bloody Marxists always
say that wasn't real Marxism it's like
oh how many millions of people have to
die before you're convinced that it's
real Marxism and I know what they mean
by that - they mean hey if I was the
Marxist dictator things would have gone
a lot better it's like ah you should
think again sunshine if you are the
Marxist dictator things wouldn't have
gone a lot better
so and if you're the sort of person that
thinks that if you would have been
control things would have gone a lot
better then you're exactly the sort of
person who should never be in control so
and it's resentment
it's horrible resentment you know that's
an important point because I think this
is something that you said that I
absolutely agree with it I think a lot
of this thinking and the way people are
behaving
it seems based on revenge it seems based
on revenge for awkward upbringing social
uncomfortable uncomfortability it seems
like there's something about the way
they view the world where they want to
get back at people that have literally
done them no wrong
it's resentment for the burden of being
it's deeper it's deeper I mean human
being human existence is characterized
by a fair bit of suffering you know
we're limited creatures and life is very
hard everyone dies everyone you love is
going to die most of the things you do
all of the things you do will eventually
fail you know suffering is a certainty
and it's very easy for people to become
resentful about about being about
existence you know these kids who shoot
up high schools and and and these mass
shooters they're they're the perfect
examples of people who run on nothing
but resentment they're out to kill the
innocent because that's the best marker
of that's the best way of showing just
how much contempt they have for
existence itself why punish the guilty
they deserve to be punished it's a lot
more malevolent and and and and and
vengeful to punish the innocent it's
like people are motivated to a great
degree by resentment of being and a huge
chunk of that is manifested in got to
the dark side of the ideological
possession so I get to decide who my
enemies are and then I get to go after
them and I can go after them for every
single thing that's ever been done to me
that isn't good and well a lot of that's
just built into the structure of
existence then they group up they
exhibit confirmation bias they all form
some sort of a groupthink and then they
act accordingly and this is what you've
been warning against and this is where I
completely agree with you and that's why
I think the subject is so important and
I love the way you've outlined all the
steps and the problems with Marxism and
ideologies in general that we are
dealing with this these are the
beginning steps of it and people who
look at it now they say it's social
change social justice it's not it's not
it's not that's right it's not and we're
this is not going to improve things
implementing these policies will make
things worse they've made things worse
every single place they've ever been
implemented and often they've made
things so much worse that you actually
can't imagine it and people don't do the
reading I've done the reading I've done
the reading I know how bad things can
get they can get so bad that no matter
how bad you think they are you're not
even in the bloody ballpark well it's
just so strange that these sort of
courses and these sort of ideologies are
thriving in universities and it's really
disconcerting to someone who has
children you know that your children are
gonna go there in the country schools
you know I think I think that wow I
think guy is teaching Harvard just says
send them to trade school the
universities I think the universities I
think you can make a reasonable case
that the universities do more harm than
good now I hate to say that
you